If you had to put forward a thesis about
how the West should think about Islam,
what would it be? The thesis would be
that Islam is
not just another religion, it's an
entire coherent political system. A lot
of people are approaching Sharia, which
is usually loosely translated as Islamic
law.
And they they have no problem condemning
it, a lot of Americans, you know, Greg
Abbott, Trump. Abbott said like there's
no room for Sharia in in Texas, for
example. And that's all well and good,
but I think as people start learning,
well, guess what? Sharia and Islam are
inherently the same. You know, one I
call one Islam the descriptive name of
the religion and Sharia is the
prescriptive application.
So, that's I guess that would be my
ultimate thesis, which is, you know,
maybe you see what Sharia is, maybe you
don't like it, maybe you find it
incompatible with the West, but guess
what? That's not just some weird
accretion that some radicals do. That is
Islam.
All right, so when I'm reading the stuff
you write, when I hear you talk on the
internet, there feels like a sense of a
warning that you're giving the West
about Islam that we're not taking it
seriously enough. Something along those
lines. Does that feel fair? From the
very beginning of Islam in the 7th
century after Muhammad dies in Arabia is
consolidated under the banner of Islam,
they go on the Jihad according to
Islamic teaching.
And in one century from the death of
Muhammad 632 to 732, they literally have
conquered three quarters of the
Christian world, which most people have
no idea about, okay? When people hear of
countries like Egypt and Syria or
Turkey, they just have in their mind
this vague idea that they were always
either Muslim or kind of Eastern. Yeah.
No, they were actually, if you went in
the 7th century, that was Christianity
was more ingrained in Egypt, in [snorts]
Turkey, in Syria, in Morocco, Mauritania
and in Tunisia, you know, the father of
Western theology, Augustine, he's from
Tunisia. He's a North African, he was a
Berber. Okay? And most of the the early
fathers were Egyptians and Syrians and
so forth. And uh you had five seas, five
major centers. One was Rome, the other
four, Alexandria, Antioch, Jerusalem,
and Constantinople, all got conquered by
Islam. So, it was a long constant war
that went on literally for over a
millennium, okay? Century after century,
whenever Muslims could, obviously there
were times when it was an ebb and flow
and due to the vicissitudes of
circumstances and Muslims weren't strong
enough, they wouldn't attack. But, any
such time that they were strong, they
conquered. So, I just told you, I gave
you the date 732, one century, because
that's the Battle of Tours and that's
where Islam is finally stopped in the
center of France. Spain has been now
been conquered. All of North Africa has
been conquered. The greater Middle East
has been conquered. And then later,
Turkey gets conquered, which is one of
the most ancient Christian regions.
That's where St. Paul sent many of his
letters. It features in the Book of
Revelation. There was a long constant
war and annexation of Christian
territories by Islam, historically, just
as a fact. And why did they do it? So,
even if you find a historian who is
willing to talk about this, they'll give
them their national names, okay? They'll
talk about the Arab conquest. They'll
talk about the the Moors in Spain.
They'll talk about the Turks and they'll
talk about the Tatars and the Mongols.
They'll call them Saracens.
And when you hear it that way, as I did
in college,
you're prone to just think, okay, these
are different warring groups, just like
in Europe. The French and the English
are warring. It's not There's no
ideological component necessarily.
But, if you dig into the sources, as I
have, the primary sources, including
from the Muslim sources, they see
themselves not necessarily as Turks or
Arabs, but as Muslims, first and
foremost.
And their rationale for war on whoever,
let's say Christians, is you're an
infidel. And uh you know, that's the
rule of Islam and we have to attack you
and give you the three choices, convert,
die, or pay tribute and be a
second-class citizen, etc., etc. And so,
my point is it was a long constant
massive war that went on that swallowed
up most of the Christian West, okay? You
know, we call it the West because it's
west of what? Well, west
it it was when we think of the West it
now it has its own kind of connotation.
But historically in the medieval era it
was it was west because it was the
westernmost portion of Christianity that
didn't get conquered.
Okay, it was the final appendage,
Europe.
And there was a constant warfare,
constant struggle that went on, you
know, Islamic pirates would go as far as
Iceland in the 16th century for raids
and they would come back with loads of
slaves.
America's first war, most people are
unaware,
as a nation following independence from
Britain was with Muslims who were again
again using the same logic and it's
interesting because it comes out in the
writings of Thomas Jefferson,
um you know, this paragon of
enlightenment who had of course
obviously forgotten about those Muslims
and didn't really understand what was
going on, but
they were enslaving American sailors in
their vessels. They would raid the
pirates, Muslim pirates from Barbary.
And Adams, John Adams and Jefferson met
with one of the ambassadors from Barbary
and basically and we have the existent
letter
where where Jefferson wrote a letter to
Congress saying what happened in the
meeting.
And he says, "We told him, look, can't
we just be friends? We have nothing
against you. You can do your religion
and let's let's engage in trade. Let's
help each other." And then Jefferson
writes and the man answered us and said,
"It's in our Quran. You're the enemy.
You're the infidel. We must wage war on
you, etc., etc., okay?"
So, I tell you all that by way to answer
your question about the warning, okay?
So, this has been going on for
over a millennium. This being we are
ideologically driven, we are going to
wage warfare to conquer the infidel.
>> Right. And we've have conquered. Bring
back the fire.
Bring back the
Bring back the fire and the
back the fire
and
the righteous name.